giada i'm so excited because you're
about to meet
a drew gooder um and she's from chicago
and she has a very special connection to
you um
she and her dad used to talk about you
all the time and oh wow recently passed
away two years ago
and if it's okay we'll meet her hear her
story and then
you could surprise her yes
okay this is so fun thank you so much
giada okay
our next guest is a drew gooder from
chicago illinois who uses her catering
company to cook
and deliver meals to hospitals in the
chicago
area please welcome antonella to the
show
hi how are you i'm so
good how are you good thank you for
having me
i know that hospitals and you
have a very close connection um
and i was wondering if you could tell us
how you've been using your business and
your love of food
to give back to them well um
i've been a chef for about 16 years now
and
once cobit hit i just wanted to use my
resources to see
how i can give back so i started with
the hospitals
and you've delivered meals now to 15
different hospitals
and you have that special connection i
spoke of
um to a few of them would you tell us
about those
sure um my my father recently passed
away on it's actually
two years uh on the 12th of this month
and
he was always a pretty sick guy so um
he was in various amounts of hospitals
and
you know being by his bedside he always
always always wanted us to take care of
the nurses the doctors
so um that and then my wife and i had
twin girls um
they're almost two and you know they
spent a
long time in the nicu as well um
so we just i just have so much respect
for for those on the front line
i am i admire your story so much
because i think we all have to
experience
um different obstacles in our lives but
what you
do with them is just some of us
fall to the side and we get weak and
frustrated and confused
some of us overcome but the fact that
you
not only overcome but you give back is
just
it's so incredible and um
i know that you and your dad um would
cook together and being in the kitchen
together and i was
wondering um who that person is that
inspires you as a chef that you guys
would talk about um
you know growing up in an all-italian
home um
my dad my dad you know he um he didn't
really
he he loved watching uh the food network
uh one specific chef
he used to always watch and my mom used
to always tease him like oh you know
your dad's watching that um
that chef now on tv and i don't know if
it was a little bit of uh it was a cute
jealousy that she had that you know
another italian woman and he was
watching
uh cook so um i started watching with
them and it was uh giada
um it was just it was just watching
something so close to home uh her
italian inspiration
she's definitely an inspiration of mine
well
um um i would love to just uh invite
someone in here to say hello to you uh
giada are you there
i'm here
oh my goodness i am so
honored you made me blush as well
i mean you made her bless me cry
i mean you know what you're doing is
amazing i think that um
people like you give us all so much
inspiration
to be to show good in this world and to
love each other no matter what
um so i'm so honored to be here to get
to meet you
god it's like it's it's crazy thank you
so much
this is such a huge
huge gift so i appreciate it thank you
well we really appreciate you
and um i heard you're a fan of the
humble potato which i am such a fan of
yes i love potatoes i uh i married an
irish woman so she loves potatoes
oh wow yeah we're potato family
and you have a potato dish in particular
that you really love to make
right it's it's something simple it's
just
potatoes you know cutting them in
quarters a whole lot of olive oil
garlic fresh herbs i love thyme i love
rosemary i love a little bit of parsley
at the end
salt and pepper you know getting that
crisp
on the potato is is is key that's you
know when you scrape it off the pan
that's my favorite part of the potatoes
so uh
yes we us italians we we love the crispy
potatoes so um we
fight for those crispy anything yes
thank you
i would love to learn how to rock those
crispy
wonder potatoes that you make and our
friends actually at the little potato
company want to give you a ten thousand
dollar check
so that you can continue making meals
for those amazing people in need that
you are making those meals
for and that's not all the little potato
company also wants to give you
a year's worth of blizzard
potatoes
[Applause]
well i cannot thank you antonella
enough and giada and bobby and giada
in italy is on discovery plus it's so
wonderful
go binge it right now thank you so much
you guys thank you so much thanks for
letting me be in this
[Music]
circle